15 قتيلا في هجمات صاروخيه اسرائيليه في
كفر سوسه ومناطق محيطه بالعاصمه السوريه
المعارضه التركيه تتهم الحكومه بالتقصير
وتربط تاخر جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال
بتراكم السلطه اردوغان
مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه تحبط خمسه عشر
مخططا ايرانيا لقتل او خطف بريطانيين
معارضين لنظام طهران
[موسيقى]
طب ثم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
الاخبار من العربيه افاد المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان بان ضربه جويه اسرائيليه
استهدفت منطقه كفر سوسه بقلب العاصمه
السوريه دمشق مؤكدا وقوعها 15 قتيلا على
الاقل جراء تلك الغارات واضاف المرصد
السوري انه يوجد منشات تابعه لايران بينها
مدرسه في المناطق المستهدفه بينما تحدث
جيش النظام السوري عن سقوط خمسه قتلى
بينهم جندي في الهجوم
[موسيقى]
ضربات وليست ضربه واحده في دمشق على الاقل
في منطقه المزرعه هناك دمار في منزل
ومعلومات عن خساره بشريه في كفر سوسه منزل
منهاره بشكل شبه كامل في هذا الحي او هذه
المنطقه التي يوجد فيها مركز ايراني ثقافي
او احد المراكز التابعه للايرانيين ايضا
كان هناك انفجار شديد في جنوب دمشق
المنطقه الواقعه بين السيده زينب
والمطار وايضا كان هناك في محافظه
السويداء يوجد دفاعات جويه جرى استهدافها
في كفر سوسه كما قلنا المدرسه الايرانيه
هل سقط الصاروخ بالفعل على المدرسه
الايرانيه ام على مبدا بالقرب المدرسه
الايرانيه اذا ما كان الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي لمبنى هذا يدل بان اسرائيل
لديها معلومات عن وجود شخصيه ما ايرانيه
او لحزب الله او شخصيه مهمه حقيقه الامر
[موسيقى]
اكدت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه في بيان
انها نفذت توا شركائها المحليون غاره
بطائرته هليكوبتر في شمال شرق سوريا يوم
امس اسفرت عن القاء القبض على احد قيادي
داعش ويدعى بتار وهو متورط في التخطيط
لهجمات على مراكز الاحتجاز الخاضعه لحرس
لحراسه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد وتصنيع
العبوات الناسفه
اعلنا رئيس اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه يونس سيزر ارتفاعها حصيله اعداد
قتل الزلزال الذي ضرب ولايات جنوبيه
البلاد ارتفاعه الى اربعين الف
شخصا وقال سيزر ان الزلزال او الزلازل
اثرت على ما يقرب من عشره الاف حيث سكني
في احد عشر ولايه جنوبي البلاد
منذ اللحظات الاولى لانتشال الطفله
السوريه عفراء من تحت الانقاض في جنديرس
وبعد ان تمت معالجتها في احد المستشفيات
قرب عفرين والتحقق من هويات اقاربها جرى
لم شمل الطفل الرضيعه وتسليمها الى عمتها
وزوجها خليل السوادي وسمياها عفراء على
اسم والدتها المتوفى الى جانب افراد
اسرتها في كارثه الزلزال المدمر وقال زوج
عمه الطفل خليل السوادي ان هذه الطفله
تعني الكثير له ولاسرته مضيفا انها ستبقى
ذكرى له ولزوجته ولجميع الاقارب في قريه
والديها
شعوري ما يوصف
فرحه يعني صار لها عشره ايام شفتني عايش
على اعصابي يعني عم استنى هاللحظه هاي
والحمد لله
معي زوجته وابني
والحمد لله يعني يعني كله قانوني امورنا
كلها قانونيه صارت اجراءات كلها قانونيه
اعلن المركز اليورو متوسطيه عن تسجيل هزه
ارضيه جديده بدرجه 5.5 من عشره ضربت وسط
تركيا مساء اليوم قبل مساء قبل ذلك قال
منسق الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
للازمه السوريه ان المواد المقدمه
للسوريين المنكوبين اثر الزلزال هي
مساعدات تتعلق بالحرب مؤكدا ان مئات
العائلات بلا ماوى الاحتياجات اكبر بكثير
من القدره الموجوده لدينا حاليا لحد الان
الامم المتحده ادخلت لحد امس ما يقارب ال
180 شاحنه هاي الشاحنات
يوجد عليها طبعا مواد غذائيه
بطانيات خيم لايواء مؤقت
ادوات صحيه وما يلزم وما يلزم المتضررين
منسق الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه قال
ان السعوديه ساهمت بشكل كبير في مساعده
المتضررين في سوريا وتركيا نحن نعمل مع مع
الجهات المانحه ومع جميع الدول عملنا نداء
نداء استغاثه ب 400 مليون دولار لخلال
الثلاثه اشهر القادمه نامل انه يوصل الدعم
المادي حتى نتمكن من تامين كل هذه
الاحتياجات طبعا احنا يعني في هاي
المناسبه نشكر الدول التي تساعدتنا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا ما قصروا
بعثوا كل بعتوا الطائرات لمساعده السوريين
ولمساعده ولمساعده الاتراك في هذا المحنه
اللي بيمروا فيها دول الجوار الاردن
والعراق والدول والدول الاخرى
فور انقاذ الناجين بطانيات الومنيوم
تخطيهم
طورها مركز مارشيلا تابع لناسا عام
1973 لتبريد محطه
بطانيات الالومنيوم تستخدم عند حدوث
الكوارث او برحلات الفضاء غطاء بلاستيكي
قوي مع طلاء الومنيوم وعاكس للاشعه تحت
الحمراء
ذهبيه او فضيه اللون تعرف ببطانيات الفضاء
او الطوارئ بطانيات خفيفه لا يتجاوز وزنها
85 غراما مقاومه للماء ومضاده للرياح
وناقله للاوزان الثقيله تساعد على تدفئه
الجسم في الاجواء البارده او تعديل حرارته
تساعد على منع التعرق وبقاء الجسم جافا ما
يحفظ الطاقه
رصدت كاميرا العربيه عمليه انتشار عائله
سوريه على قيد الحياه في مدينه انطاكيا
بولايه هاتاي حيث نجا الاب والام وطفلهما
البالغ من العمر 12 سنه بعد
296 ساعه تحت الانقاض لكن بعد انتشار
الطفل بدقائق فارق الحياه متاثرا باصابه
تعرض لها لحظه انهيار المنزل
جهود الانقاذ في مدينه انطاكيا بولايه
هاتاي ما زالت مستمره في محاوله للوصول
الى اشخاص ما زالوا عالقين تحت الانقاض في
هذا الموقع نجح فريق انقاذ من قرغيزستان
بانتشال عائله سوريه مكونه من اب وام وطفل
بعمر 12 عاما كانوا احياء عند انتشار
الطفل كان مصابا واثناء محاولات فرق
الانقاذ والطواقم الطبيه انقاذه توفي
الطفل وبقي الاب والام بحاله جيده وتم
نقلهما الى مشفى في مدينه اضنه ايضا تم
انتشاء الجثتين لطفلين تعتقد السلطات
انهما اطفال العائله السوريه التي تم
انقاذها وتم نقل الاب والام الى اضنه في
العموم اعمال البحث والانقاذ ما زالت
مستمره في 300 موقع وتحديدا في اربع
ولايات في هاتاي كهرمان مرعش وبدرجه اقل
في اديوامان في ديار بكر في موقع وحيد
زيدان زنجلو من مدينه انطاكيا
بعد اسبوعين على الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
تتبادل الحكومه والمعارضه الاتهامات عن
التقصير في مواجهه الازمه ليرشحها البعض
لتكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات المرتقبه
في تركيا توصل الاحزاب المعارضه توجيها
الانتقادات لسياسه الحكومه في التعاطي مع
الزلزال لتؤكد بان حجم الكارثه اظهر عجزا
في التعاطي معها فعواقب الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب عده مدن تركيه ستستمر طويلا
وستكون النقطه الابرز على حملات
الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه التي
ستعقد خلال اشهر وتاخذها حكومه اردوغان
على انها التحدي الاكبر للتخفيف من
تداعيات الزلزال المدمر
وفق تقرير نشرته وكاله بلومبرك قال احد
زعماء المعارضه ان تراكم السلطه السياسيه
بيد اردوغان وضعف الاستجابه السريعه اعاق
جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
وباتت السلطات اقل كفاءه من جديد غير ان
الحكومه ردت ووصف التصريحات الاحزاب
المعارضه بغير اللائقه داعيه في الوقت
نفسه لتظفر كافه الجهود مع تزايد حده
التممل والاستياء في وسط المواطنين مشيره
ان اردوغان اقر ببطء الاستجابه للزلزال
وان تحقيقا سيفتح لمعرفه الاسباب
الزلزال الذي ادى لانهيار الاف البنايات
وتسبب في مقتل العشرات وتشريد الملايين
يمكن ان يكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات
ومده للتنفس بين اردوغان واحزاب المعارضه
جو مشحون بالتوترات السياسيه وحتى
الاقتصاديه تنظر بانتخابات صعبه على
الطرفين خصوصا اذا توافقت المعارضه ونجحت
بتقديم مرشح مشترك لمنافسه اردوغان
اقامه الجاليه السوريه في بريطانيا خيمه
عزاء شعبي للتضامن مع ابناء الجاليه ممن
فقدوا ذويهم او لم تصلهم اخبار بعد عن
عائلتهم بعد الزلزال الذي طرب سوريا
[موسيقى]
لازم اكون موجود مع اهلي بهذا الظرف
الاستثنائي
بس للاسف ما عنا شي بالوقت الحالي بنقدر
نعمله غير انه نكون نحن هون مع بعض نحاول
نجمع شي ونبعثه للمناطق المتضرره
[موسيقى]
تحيه المساحه الصغيره يلي عم تخلينا نقعد
مع بعض
ونزعل مع بعض نحزن
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
ماكرون يرغب بخساره روسيا في اوكرانيا
حياكم الله جدد رئيس وحده مكافحه الارهاب
بشرطه لندن مات جوكس تمكن السلطات الامنيه
من احباط خمسه عشره مخططا ارهابيا ايرانيا
لخطف او قتل بريطانيين او اشخاص تعتبرهم
طهران اعداء للنظام الايراني وفقا لصحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه واكد جوكس ان قرار
قناه ايران انترناشونال المعارضه غلق
مكاتبها في لندن ونقل البث الى واشنطن جاء
على خلفيه تصاعد التهديدات من دول معاديه
من دون ان يكشف عنها ونقلت الصحيفه عن
جوكس قوله ان مجموعه من الاجراءات الامنيه
الوقائيه اتخذت خلال العامين الماضيين
للتعامل مع تهديدات لاهداف اخرى مقرها
المملكه المتحده
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان علاقه المملكه مع الولايات
المتحده
تراحي المصالح القوميه
نحن متحدون تجاه كافه القضايا التي تقف
بجانب القانون الدولي في علاقتنا مع
الولايات المتحده نراعي مصالحنا القوميه
صحيح اننا نختلف مع واشنطن في بعض القضايا
وهذا امر معلن ومعروف وخلافه مع امريكا
محدده في قضايا معينه اود ان اشير الى
اننا نعمل مع امريكا في قضايا امن
واستقرار المنطقه
[موسيقى]
في طريقه عودته من مؤتمر ميونخ للامنه قال
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون انه يريد
هزيمه روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا وان
تتمكن اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن موقفها وتبع
مكرونه انه لا يعتقد بضروره هزيمه روسيا
بالكامل ومهاجمتها على اراضيها مشيرا الى
ان البعض يريد قبل اي شيء سحق روسيا ولكن
هذا ليس موقف فرنسا ولن يكون كذلك ابدا
في ملف الحربي في اوكرانيا اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلاده تواصل
التنسيق مع شركائها من اجل دعم كيف امنيا
واقتصاديا وانسانيا
التضامن مع اوكرانيا ودعمها لا يزال اقوى
من اي وقت مضى وهناك تصميم كبير بين جميع
البلدان الممثله هنا تقريبا على مواصله
هذا الدعم وضمان انتصار اوكرانيا وصمودها
في وجه العدوان الروسي
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نادي برايس ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
تشاور هاتفيا مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو والرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس بشكل منفصل وكرر دعم بلاده لحل
دولهين وحظ الطرفين على اعاده الهدوء
واضاف برايس ان بلانكن اكد على التزام
الولايات المتحده الصارم بامن اسرائيل
في تونس تطوى مرحله الايقافات التي قامت
بها الاجهزه الامنيه اسبوعها الاول تطوير
اسبوعها الاول وقد شملت قيادات من الصف
الاول في النهضه وناشطين سياسيين ورجاء
الاعمال وقضى معزولينا وقيادات امنيه في
الوقت يؤكد الرئيس سعيد ان الاعتقالات على
صله متهمين بالتامر على امن الدوله ويرى
معارضوه ان الخطوه هي تصفيه لخصوم سياسي
ايقافات ستتلوها اخرى هكذا ينطلق القضاء
التونسي في التعامل مع متهمين بالاعتداء
على امن الدوله قيادات محسوبه على النهضه
من سياسيين وامنيين ورجال اعمال وقضاه
معزولين هم الان رهن الايقاف والسجن في
انتظار استكمال مسار الاصلاح بعد
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه هكذا يتحدث الشارع
التونسي المشغول بهموم قوت يومه من الندور
تلقى الازمات وراء الازمات راهم اللي هما
كانهم الدوله مويسيه معناها مش معناها
المسؤولين قاعدين يحكموا هم قائمين بدور
الدوله الموازيه الايقافات متاخره برشا
طريقه ايقافات هي اللي متشرفش الشعب
التونسي ومتشرفش الثوره التونسيه
عبر التاريخ يؤكد الرئيس سعيد في رد على
منتقديه من الداخل والخارج ان مطلب
المحاسبه الشعبيه وان كل الاجراءات
قانونيه محترمه سياده الدوله واحده كما
يقول
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
الا ان مساله سياده الدوله تثار عند
المتابعين بين عملي اجهزتها للحفاظ على
استمرار الدوله او العوده الى مربع
الارتهان للخارج او الدخول الى منطقه
الفوضى
نتحدث عن ايقافات اليوم يجب ان نتجاوز
مساله مجرد المناوشات السياسيه طبيعه
الاسماء التي اوقفت في القضيه تحيل الى
قضيه امن دوله بامتياز بمعنى هناك مخطط
لاسقاط السلطه القائمه لم يتوانى القائمون
به على التصحيح به علنا يعني هناك من قال
لرئيس الجمهوريه لديك مهله للخروج الامن
هناك من استنجد بالاجهزه
لاسقاط الدوله
ورغم الجدل المسار اليوم حول الايقافات
الاخيره الا ان جل المتابعين يؤكدون انها
محطه اخرى على درب تعديل البوصله واستكمال
الخيار الاصلاحيه والاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في البلاد وا قوس منظومه الاخوان والفساد
وليد عبد الله العربيه تونس
افادت مصادر العربيه في افغانستان عن
مبادره لوزير الداخليه طالبان سراج الدين
حقاني بتاسيس مجلس شورى للحكم في الحركه
بهدف انهاء احتكار السلطه من قبل القياده
في قندهار
قوه سائله في الاتساع بين قيادات طالبان
بدايتها كانت خطابات من وزير الداخليه
سراج الدين حقاني ينتقد فيها تزمر قرارات
قائد الحركه ملاهبه الله اخوان زاده بشكل
غير مباشر ولكن سرعان ما تحول الخطاب
المبهم الى تحرك واضح حقاني طرح فكره
انشاء مجلس شورى تناقش في اطاره السياسات
والقرارات بعيدا عن هيمنه قياده قندهار
جاء هذا بعد انطعاد القيادات في كابول من
رفض اخوان زاده مقابلتهم ونقاشهم بخصوص
تعليم الفتيات وعمل النساء القرار الذي
وسع الهوه بين طالبان ودول العالم في
الوقت الذي تحتاج فيه افغانستان الى
المساعدات الدوليه لما تعانيه من فقر شديد
يكاد ان يصل بشعبها الى مجاعه قاتله
نظام اخوان زاد في الحكم شمولي حيث يتدخل
في الشؤون المدنيه والعسكريه على حد سواء
وهنا اتفق وزير الداخليه مع وزير الدفاع
ملا محمد يعقوب الذي يمتلك اهميه رمزيه
كونه ابن مؤسس الحركه الملا عمر هذا
الاتفاق يهدف الى محاوله التغيير السلمي
عبر مجلس الشورى ولكن في بلاد كافغانستان
لا تعرف ثقافه الحوار الا اذا كانت اصوات
المتحاورين ممتزجه باصوات اطلاق النار لا
يتوقع المراقبون ان تنجح سلميه التغيير
فهناك انباء عن قرب تنصيب رئيس جديد
للوزراء مقرب للقائد ومتشدد مثله هو قاضي
القضاه عبد الحكيم حقاني الامر الذي سيؤدي
الى تعزيز النهج المتزمت في تسيير
افغانستان انسنا ماسي
قالت كوريا الشماليه انها اختبرت صاروخا
باليسيا عابرا للقارات في البحر قباله
الساحل الغربي لليابان بعد ظهر امس واكدت
استعدادها لهجوم مضاد نوويه قاتل ضد
القوات المعاديه وقالت وكاله الانباء
الحكوميه ان الصاروخ اجتاز
989 كيلومترا خلال 67 دقيقه وبلغ اقصى
ارتفاع له
578 كيلومترا قبل ان يصيب بدقه منطقه
محدده مسبقا في المياه المفتوحه
طلب الرئيس الامريكي السابق جيمي كارتارا
مغادره المستشفى بعد قضائه فترات متقطعه
للعلاج هناك ونقله الى بيته العائلي لقضاء
ما تبقى له من وقت مع افراد اسرته
وسيلتقي كارترا الذي يبلغ 98 عاما او
يتلقى رعايه في بيته وهو يعاني منذ سنوات
من سلسله من المشكلات الصحيه التي تطلبت
دخوله المستشفى مرات العده منذ العام 2019
في نهايه النشره تذكيرهم بابرز العناوين
15 قتيلا في هجمات صاروخيه اسرائيليه في
كفر سوسه ومناطق محيطه بالعاصمه السوريه
المعارضه التركيه تتهم الحكومه بالتقصير
وتربط تاخر جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال
بتراكم السلطه بيدي اردوغان
مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه تحبط خمسه عشر
مخططايرانيا لقتل او خطف بريطانيين
معارضين لنظام طهران
القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]